após muito mais um vídeo de hoje é
resultado de um estúdio nem falam dois e
vamos contar já porque lá então o maior
valor alcançado da esquerda para a
direita e ele tem uma vez fica com uma
ideia melhor porque mesmo quando a
câmera de longe não dá pra perceber
muito mais que ainda vão estar
acostumados com vários tamanhos que dão
muito já estão 36 borrachas que recebeu
vez toda escuridão que muitos já
exportem porque elas são transparentes e
conseguiu logo que eu preciso arrumar
nada para fugir não vou dar profundidade
à mesa e voltar logo sei quantos ponha
mesa era impossível da gaveta quando
acabar as gavetas ou 215 e já saída para
de quito tem e depois do tri as coisas
que mais nos meus projetos e os vídeos
se eu faço pelo qual o nome e nem qual
fica mais necessitado qualquer coisa
dizendo que lá enfim tenho uma das 27 11
entorno o inter ao lado do chefe dessa
mulher gasta pouca energia em comparação
com os top box estudar aqui uma 18ª
maneira que eu prendo a mesa para não
chegar à mesa extra gostava quando
estava a ficar muito mal falam então a
capital goiânia vai continuar sua boa
forma deste momento é às vezes você vê o
fundo verde também não fica presa em
cima desta vez que tem uma abertura e
equipamentos apenas que eu uso como
fundo para os vídeos organizado
essa máquina que por não ter conflito de
estuprar uma das minhas cenas que já
completa
agora vou mostrar um estudo de longe
o tópico sobre aquilo e enquanto ela
quer lugar o estado já humberto mas não
está fácil mas ainda ainda é bom por
aqui para não tenho como responder o
trabalho de criar alguma coisa alguma
coisa que não teve que usar em cada uma
delas
o paulo gosta mesmo de armas usadas por
ela era uma coisa que eu queria estudar
então feito nas transições políticas do
pudesse eu posso nem pintura a empresa
melhora porque a barriga para nós fica
no edifício 15 velho ea cor mesmo - ou
então as coisas dão mais trabalho
já com que tudo é que a volta a cantar
também brincou button branco ac a manhã
o trabalho de hoje 11 a última trabalhar
mais a bola e construir as coisas
secretas
aquela minha cozinha melhor resultado
aqui desde lá o que vocês conseguem
desde pintores guia de testes de stress
foi a primeira filha da terra organizado
mais agora porque as grandes também que
para os objetos e mantemos a carga de
trabalho é grande
a madeira precisa potência cada uma
turma da mente 9 horas para fazer o
trajeto com muito mais barato com paula
já feitas
a vantagem que deus te fez logo a medida
certa e venceu o quarto traz como
embalagem que pode apoiar as duas coisas
que encontrou então as duas numa fresta
[Música]
o nome apresentado pelo menos pudesse
dica fica muito giro foi de r 11
encontrar no papel os bons porque a
assembléia e pôs no terceiro quarto
então agora vou ligar luz mas elas são
tão fortes que eu julgo que vai com
efeito as imagens
[Música]
o trabalho tanto trabalho de vídeo